Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Alright,
here we go.
I'm going over the new bridge,
the three years.
Oh,
there we go.
We
go.
Oh,
oh,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
We're going to be like 20 like 20 Oh
[inaudible]
you split up.
That was so funny.
I can't believe it.
I spit my water out.
I don't want to turn the wrong earphones or you know,
live it at me,
dude.
There's,
there's snow up.
I can't hear my song.
You can hear yourself.
No.
And Mike,
is my mic on?
Yeah,
it's on no gene.
Hello.
Hello,
hello.
Oh,
there it is.
Okay.
Twist in the wrong line.
You want to know something yesterday what?
I had top dog and Charo in here.
We'll get to that obviously a little bit later.
Yeah,
30 minutes into talking to them.
I play something for them to watch and my dad goes,
I can't hear it.
And I go,
you can't hear it.
And he goes,
no.
I go,
well,
can you hear me right now?
And he goes,
no,
he never played them in.
Now they were just sat with headphones on.
I'm unplugged.
Not even like didn't it to you that there was no sound coming through?
No.
It's so funny because they're so accustomed to whatever is happening.
Like they just,
you know,
it's kind of like how busy is they give you,
put like a towel on her head.
She just lets it stay there.
I wanna I wanna give credit for that song.
Oh my God.
River by Matt Mercer.
That was so funny.
The way he spit out.
I took a sip of water and then I had to spit it back into the Fiji bottle.
That was so funny.
That was great.
The,
the composition of the Dad Boehner was outstanding.
His enthusiasm is just ridiculous.
Yeah.
Look at the river.
Decided about driving on a fucking bridge.
Somebody sent in an anti dad.
Boehner supposed to play that little,
oh goodness.
There's a lot to talk about.
I mean,
we had my parents here for five days.
It was a world wind,
a situation,
a whirlwind weekend.
Not a whirlwind.
It's a world when there was a blessing in disguise.
Wow.
It was a,
it was artistic.
It was,
it was voluptuous.
Um,
yeah.
Listen over listening to say welcome to all our new listeners.
Welcome to your mom's house.
And um,
there's a lot to go over today.
Oh my God.
Last few weeks have been big weeks on this show because we had Martin Resa,
uh,
the water sound.
Yay.
Is it Vasa?
Somewhere year,
that episode got a lot of traction.
A lot of people,
uh,
really interested in,
in Ah,
and what he had to say.
I haven't touched our tap water since,
I mean urban or whatever.
Buying water differently since that,
since that day I've been buying Fiji water for us.
I know,
but also even when in restaurants I'll say,
what type of water?
And the guy,
even yesterday he goes,
we have triple purified,
blah,
blah.
Or we have this spring water.
I go,
bring me the spring water.
Yeah.
I have been ordering it too.
There was a life changing experience and then a Mr Joe Rogan came last week and
that was a fun time.
That was,
that was a really fun,
yeah,
we got him to drink the Hungarian water.
Yeah.
He liked it.
I'm pretty,
pretty good stuff.
That was super fun.
Um,
okay.
Well,
uh,
why don't we,
why don't we start the show and uh,
we'll go from there.
Yeah.
Okay.
Jane,
let's,
let's do our opening clip and get good.
Yes.
It's Monday.
Look at the river.
Sophie Tanner just celebrated her second wedding anniversary two years ago.
Her poor dad walked her down the aisle in public and gave his daughter away to
herself in what's called Scilog me Sophie Tanner married herself.
Oh,
is Randy.
Don't bring it in one.
Loving to live.
Well,
co Co go to your mom's house with tone.
Civil war.
Christina.
Yeah.
There you go.
A whole new world just opened up marrying yourself.
Why are more women choosing to marry themselves?
Boy.
Bad personalities.
Yeah.
I'm thinking,
I'm thinking there.
I could think of a few reasons.
Sad,
lonely.
Because you need to look in the mirror and change things in inside and out.
What do you mean?
Why are they choosing the Marriott?
If someone's not chosen to marry you,
then you know,
here's the thing,
I just got a problem with you.
You just say single,
right?
If you're like,
Hey,
I'm not in a marriage,
which is totally valid.
They want to celebrate being single.
Oh,
like I'm,
you know what that's like,
um,
that's like a,
that's like the girls who are like,
I'm happy being saying I'm proud man.
Like,
no,
you're not.
And if you're happy,
you just,
you just start are,
you don't have to tell people,
right?
Yeah,
no,
yeah.
They want it to be there saying like,
these societal norms are unfair and,
or just,
you know,
not recognizing that that's something to celebrate.
In other words,
they celebrate you being with somebody else,
but what about celebrating me not being with somebody else?
She said everyone celebrates getting together with someone and becoming married,
but there's no milestone in society that celebrates escaping something awful or
returning to your own happiness.
Oh,
10 minutes.
Ouch.
Yeah.
Escaping something awful.
That,
is that what she thinks marriage is like,
I wonder what the movie she escaped a bad relationship
then.
That's a different story.
That should be a different party altogether.
Don't want a wedding.
Salami.
Erica Anderson,
who of course lives in Brooklyn also bury herself.
I think it's hard not to adopt whatever societies messages are.
And I certainly think that one of the messages is you are not enough if you are
not with someone else.
Okay.
Yeah.
Or You could just ignore societal messages and not have to something.
She seemed cute enough.
Right?
I'm sure she's fine.
Yeah.
It just must be.
Why don't you talk to her?
You're like,
Oh God,
she's a nightmare.
She fucking marry yourself.
And then she goes,
I will.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I Dunno about you acting like this is a good thing.
I don't know.
I think that,
again,
I don't care.
They don't give a shit.
The thing is,
I think they want the,
um,
the celebration of a wedding and they want to wear the dress and stuff.
I totally get that.
In which case,
isn't that kind of like a Quinceanera or like a coming out party?
We call it something else.
Like marrying yourself.
It's kind of sad.
Right?
So would you rather marry yourself or you ever date your mom?
Oh my God.
I had married myself.
I'd stay alone and sad my whole life.
My mom.
It's just like the gays.
What would you do?
Uh,
of course I would marry myself over dating my mom.
Of course.
That's so crazy.
I don't know.
I mean I feel like I've made fun of so many of these people and then you get to
know why and then you're always like,
oh okay,
well she was abused or whatever,
but just don't do this.
That's what I would say too.
I think this is probably a nice lady.
Have you talked to her?
You'd be like,
I understand,
but also could you just not do this?
Do you have to divorce yourself?
Like does she have to make this league right?
Cause this isn't legal to begin with.
Right?
Recognize you can't walk in and go,
are you single or married guy?
I'm married,
I'm married to me dance.
It's stupid.
But you know what someone will say to you,
stop fucking around.
Stop being mentally ill.
Stop being crazy and crazy.
Like in France,
they let you marry dead people.
Hmm.
Which is like not,
it's also still no point.
Yeah.
Of My dad's lonely in a relationship that's not functioning.
Measure just being on your own.
And a lot of people don't realize that you can waste your life waiting for the
one when you are the one yourself.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
I mean,
these are just these people.
They need to find therapists.
You need to find your therapist.
You're not fooling anyone.
First of all.
You know,
I'm,
I'm too strong.
I'm strong woman.
That's why.
That's why men can't handle me.
I'm a strong woman now.
You're just,
you're annoying.
Nobody likes you.
There's always a thing.
I do feel like it comes from women almost exclusively.
You know,
not to be unfair.
Um,
the can't handle me mentality guys.
I never hear guys say she couldn't handle me bro.
Like you guys never say that to women.
A lot of women who are crazy,
we'll say stuff like,
he just can't handle my success or like my personality or I'm too successful.
I'm too big.
I was like,
no,
that's not why.
I have too much this like he's successful if you know,
I think he needs a girl.
I'm a woman.
That's all code for you need,
you need help.
I remember I went out
girl a couple of times in college and then I blew her off and then months later,
you know,
I ran into her and she had this really snappy like she was,
she acted like everything was cool.
And then she was like,
uh,
have you found a girl?
Uh,
cause I know you like girls like that at the young girls and not women.
And I just wanted to be like,
look,
you're built like a fucking line backer.
Like that's,
that's why we didn't go out again.
Yeah.
I just wasn't attracted to it.
It was a physical.
Yeah.
So he,
so he thought maybe it could work and then you got to look at her and you were
like,
Nah,
I just know I went out,
we had dinner and we had drinks.
Right.
And you go like,
this is a person and everything,
but I'm not attracted to you what he's supposed to do.
You can't force,
you can't force me to track.
That's a part of that sucks about dating is that you can't just tell somebody
the truth like,
hey dude,
you know what?
I'm just not feeling.
There's no key.
Yeah.
I am like,
I could have conversations with her because she was really intelligent.
It was fun to talk to her.
I enjoyed it,
but like I'm not into you in that way.
What was their tits situation?
It was like a small medium situation.
So they weren't hungry.
They weren't more hungry.
No fall.
They were enough.
Yeah,
but like I just,
you know what?
I'm fat and sloppy.
See Bay slops like milk drops,
big g cups.
I want to hang out.
I want to put a a bucket under those tits.
I'm just dripping all night stupid.
I've had that too.
Like,
um,
when I was dating people back before Friendster was around you and I started
dating and I always found it hard to tell somebody that like,
you know what bro is just not like,
I can't say that.
I don't feel it's a horrible conversation to have.
I can't have that.
Well because they'll always interpreted it as like,
I'm not enough,
which of course it's a normal reaction and be like,
am I not enough and we're not cool enough for this person?
I might not attractive and my to this to that.
And you're like,
no dude,
they could be a fucking loser.
And they just did you a huge favor by resource course,
but marrying yourself.
Isn't that like a public declaration of sadness?
Like here's the saddest person?
No,
this is another level.
This is another level.
And also this lease sort of a dead ringer for you to fuck.
I'm serious.
I hate you.
I love her outfit though.
[inaudible]
you hear what she said?
She's marrying a train.
A train depot,
a train depot.
The train station essentially.
But I noticed that her gear is a lot like what you would wear her.
She has,
I love her.
Fanny looks like a onesy.
Hell Yeah Dude.
She has a similar cans,
right?
Yep.
Do you think that she's wearing a good bra or no?
Check,
check,
check.
No,
no.
She needs to come with me to Nordstrom and get fed and get fitted.
But I like her style.
I like where she's going in life.
Yeah.
I almost have more respect for her marrying the train station.
Just because it's something outside of yourself.
It's a little,
it's very narcissistic and solipsistic to be like,
I love me,
me,
me.
Then your urine.
If you're,
if you're all about you your whole life,
you're going to be miserable.
At least she's into the train station mean for our listeners.
Could you describe her?
Emphasize saying you with dark hair.
Can you,
can you,
yeah,
totally.
Me as she's mean,
she's my twin Brunette.
She's okay.
She's a little bit of what you would call dumpy.
That's a dumpy look.
Uh,
like it's like a mechanics outfit,
but pink,
she's not wearing a bra at all,
so they're really low and hanging and then she's got like an awesome fanny pack
is black just kind of,
she looks like droopy dog a little bit.
Yeah.
But whatever did.
She's happy cliff's tits man
as the Santa Fe train,
and I know her.
She's lesbian partner.
Debra Santa Fe
daydream gave her name but she has to share her wife with all these people.
Does that upset her?
It doesn't seem like she was that upset.
Look,
this thing has a water bottle in it.
I know that they should be like up around this area.
Right.
So I could just hire and that's all that is is a lack of a bra the right size.
I mean she has something on it.
I see it here.
It could be,
no,
I think it might be the wire.
Oh right.
That they had a lot on just sitting right now.
Wow.
I mean wouldn't that be better for her back to where a good one.
Better for everybody.
It's actually better for all of society if she does cause we don't want to look
at it.
It's like that woman we saw at the restaurant.
Yeah.
There is a lady that walked into the restaurant we were dining at who had
hangers just like they were lower though.
They were down here near the waist.
She has all buttons,
the whole,
it's all bad.
And that lady was wearing like a like or top and the restaurant.
So the fabric is very unforgiving.
It shows your flaws.
The tits had picked up momentum.
Like you know when they hit each other,
they go in circles and they hit each other and then she sat down and then we all
took turns getting up to go to the bathroom.
But they were under the table
under the table.
Imagine that you're at a table and some ladies tits are sitting underneath the
table.
That's where they were.
And can I tell you as somebody who,
when I take my bra off,
this is what my tits look like now more or less.
But I wear bras dude,
cause I don't want to present myself like this.
Like a crazy person.
Oh boy.
[inaudible]
I really could see you wearing that.
I feel like you've worn versions of that.
Probably.
I actually pointed out an output to your mother yesterday.
Identical to that at Nordstrom.
I did.
Um,
you think she's mentally ill?
Severely,
but at least,
again,
this is an externalization of,
of one's stuff,
you know what I mean?
Like at least give your love to something or someone a building,
an external.
She's kissing,
touching the walls.
I like how
might and will you pick up the audio?
Only from the camera.
Really good job guys.
[inaudible]
oh,
so her in the building watch buildings.
Yeah.
She's not doing so well.
[inaudible]
no good luck.
There should be mutual respect for it I guess so I guess that poses the ultimate
question.
Mary herself.
Mary a building near your mom.
I fuck.
I'd have to choose that.
Fuck God.
Last time I choose a building really.
Cause he can be like we at least you're technically married to something.
If it's a really beautiful,
there are beautiful buildings and then,
and the environment's fun to go to.
I would say married to a building for a little while,
like the empire state building.
Super Cool.
Yeah.
That's a good building where they let you marry it.
Who Cares?
So many suitors.
Notredame oh yeah,
that'd be cool.
I remember asking where the notes Notredame was to a local policemen.
Yeah.
I got off the subway and I was like,
I learned that.
I think it was like,
Ooh,
the North Sudan Asca.
I went to
what she boss.
I said,
and I was like,
oh,
you just nod at the whole time and at the end he was like,
man,
there you go.
Thank you sir.
Go and ask.
MERCI.
Buckets.
Merisee buckets,
man.
Uh,
what would you do you burn building or would you marry yourself?
Nah,
I'd marry building for a while.
Like I said,
if it was a really nice building and I liked the area cause I can go to the same
place for a while.
What if we just married this house?
That'd be way easy.
Yeah.
Dude.
You don't have to go anywhere.
Hang out with your spouse all the time.
What about this level?
21 year old soccer Bruno have a Sako,
works in a supermarket and sings in a j pop band.
His girlfriend's name is Manaca,
she's 16 there are love plus couple here.
Saku slips into the role of a schoolboy and meets the virtual Manaca while
playing the game.
So it's a simulation dating like that movie.
Right?
Or I've seen that.
Yeah,
it was good movie.
It was given to me.
Is that hawking,
I forget everything.
I just signed it to check out the tennis team.
Manaca she was tending the grounds and we had a chat how our relationship
started.
Since then we've become closer and closer.
Well what's your fucking pro down is,
it doesn't seem to be the one I thought it was.
What Pronoun is is they,
they uh,
you know teeth.
What's Your Pronoun?
They got teeth pronoun like and those two pieces
really,
really kind of toeing that line.
Okay.
Pronouns.
Soco Bruno spends about three hours a day,
which is virtually,
she's always with him because a lot plus runs on a Nintendo ds,
a mobile emulator,
soccer.
We once had a real girlfriend too,
but not for long.
Now he's devoted to Monaca alone.
Yep.
Voted.
I love when they say shit like that,
like someone was devoted to their car that they are having sex with or video
games.
He is though.
I know that's it.
But the problem with that,
is this healthy?
No,
it's not because it's,
it's just going to further his isolation as he come on it.
I'm sure he,
yeah,
loads.
He makes her do stuff.
Do you think so?
All the time,
just,
just as on the screen?
Yeah.
That thing's covered.
You think so coated,
you gotta do it somewhere.
Yeah.
It's disgusting.
That's the real question.
Where are you getting that nut?
I mean,
I can get it on a building,
but right.
Cover your keys.
You could get a real problem.
It can seep into all those little nuances,
you know?
Well,
one would wonder about people's i-phones is now everyone's watching their porn
anyways.
Oh yeah.
But do people which is on their IFE.
I mean,
some people I'm sure is on your hand and then you touch your eye.
Fallen.
Now there's just on your iPhone.
Oh,
come on.
Yeah.
It's on your hand that you don't know.
Where does it go when your stomach or on your shirts or something?
Hello?
Sure.
Yeah.
I'll lay out your clothes and just on that
when you're going,
oh,
I don't care.
It's not mine.
Oh,
glass all over it.
Oh yeah,
it feels good,
man.
This is sad,
but man,
yeah,
I mean it bums me out,
but then I know how lonely some people are and this is like their only outlet.
I know.
No.
Then you're like,
oh fuck.
Just meet a person.
Yeah.
Can you swipe right on someone on Tinder or something?
I don't fucking know.
You should.
I have come all over my face,
barely the other earlier games separated reality and virtuality,
but when you play love plus real life and the game meld with one another,
it hasn't been anything like that in the gaming world before.
Yeah.
I Dunno man.
I mean,
it seems like it really is for the loneliest of the day.
It's like those sex robots,
like they're,
they're constantly trying to make a woman that's a robot so you can fuck it and
not have to talk or a problem.
Is that just,
it helps you continue to be lonely.
That's a problem.
Yeah.
You have to get out of your comfort zone to meet people.
And that's,
that's tough.
Hey,
hey,
what's going on?
He's rolling and cut.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's like a,
you just get your super,
your super lonely.
You're dating,
you're fucking Nintendo.
Yeah.
And then you're,
you're planning,
um,
you know,
fucking trenchcoat hit on somebody.
That's a problem.
Yeah.
Is it at further isolates?
Look,
human beings are meant to be social creatures.
Yeah.
You can't stay in isolation and we can't foster
it.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't marry yourself.
Don't marry your fucking Nintendo and don't marry buildings.
Go,
go find some other freaks.
It's like you and that's it.
And find him.
That's right.
Times.
Real emotional relationships can only develop,
at least in particular for us to box.
He's kissing it now.
Trust is the most important thing in a relationship.
I think braces are as a partner.
I can trust.
She never cheated on me when they get in there.
That's why I prefer her to a real girlfriend.
Yeah.
Well you go,
I love how people get hurt one time by that one issue and now it's forever.
That thing,
like,
everyone's going to cheat on me.
I can't,
I can't ever trust again.
Like,
dude,
no,
there's other girls weren't yours.
I trust it.
I trust my building was my building,
but even though the people are walking in and out of her every day,
I know there's other pigs on her.
I feel like she would never break my heart.
Well,
that was a nasty.
Um,
how's your butthole today?
That's pretty good.
Yeah.
I had a really rough week.
You back on back on normal Dr. Brown.
That was really bad.
He said,
you're going to name your next album.
No more diarrhea.
Yeah,
no more diarrhea.
Like Mary j Blige is no more drama.
I had really bad diarrhea.
I had an upper respiratory infection and I got an antibiotic.
I had never had this happen where I had the worse side effects of this
antibiotic,
which were,
which was intense diarrhea.
Yeah,
pretty bad.
It took me down for a couple days,
so just terrible.
Yeah.
Um,
all right.
A couple of emails we should get into.
Looks at Sci High Hitler's right after finishing up episode three 96 I knew I
had to email you with my observations that may give some more insight onto the
big mystery.
Who is the real water champ,
even though it really isn't a mystery.
The Tom is the champ.
But seeing it just on a mere listen from your conversation with Martin,
the Toms knowledge about the contents,
what was in each type of water was vastly superior to mommy.
Tina's okay at times as though as if Tom actually knew what was in the water
before Martin even said anything about the water,
even where it was from.
This may stem from Tom Superiority with accents.
When Mommy,
Tina Yorkie sipped her water,
she was clearly dumbfounded and what she was even tasting when she would have
thoughts about what she tasted,
it reminded me only of Helen Keller's excited cries of what,
uh,
when she discovered how to speak.
I hope I was of some help to add on the mountain of evidence for pro Tom.
So water champ.
Thanks and see you in breast balls.
Beach.
Michael.
Well,
Michael,
I hope to see you in west balls beach so I can hit you and your dumb face
because that's stupid.
How to spot a psychopath or damn.
Oh,
I like this one.
Hi Mommy.
I'm living.
I'm an American living in Singapore.
I'm sure I spotted a complete psychopath on the public bus yesterday.
It was high and tight,
cisgendered businessman in a suit,
but something was his terribly wrong.
I noticed he was wearing his watch over the
sleeve of his shirt.
How?
Boy,
what an obviously psychotic fashion choice.
Any reason I can think of to wear your watch over your sleeve is the detonate,
some type of remote bomb.
I would rather wear orthopedic shoes.
His ear muffs weigh in on this.
Thanks Jean.
Jake.
Jake,
you're completely right.
I've seen it a couple times.
He was a crazy look.
It is really bizarre.
They did it in third grade and then I realized how lame.
Yeah,
and you're like,
I can't wear my swatch over my sleep.
I also,
by the way,
I've seen it more so I know some people,
more people do it.
I think it's bananas when people wear their watch on the inside of the wrist.
That's terrible.
You know inside that goofier than Shit.
It doesn't look like a bracelet,
bro.
Like everyone knows it's a watch.
You're watching the outside like a watch.
Yeah.
You fucking asshole.
Everyone hates you now to now,
I resent people that wear their watch on the right.
Oh,
you supposed to be alive,
dude.
Always on the left.
Well,
why is it on the left?
I Dunno because I think they,
the whole thing was that more people are,
I think they said that right handed people put on their left and more people are
right handed.
Maybe that's it,
but then why wouldn't you put it on your dominant hand so that you're always
looking at that hand?
Because then the dominant hand is free to do what you need to do with the
hindrance of the watch.
Got It.
But that that is a psychopathic over look.
That's crazy.
What I feel is another psychopathic look and I know I'm going to get some
pushback on that.
Very,
very racy,
but the sandals,
like the ones I showed you today on the Vionic website,
those ugly sandals like strappy straps as are crazy dad sandals with socks.
Of course.
That's not cool.
Why would you get pushback back?
Because I know there's people are going to email me like I wear it that way
because I go,
hi.
Oh my God,
that's terrible.
It's inexcusable.
It's you.
There's no excuse to wear those period with or without socks.
It was a horrendous,
there's other options out there.
You don't talk about those strap on Gopros sandals.
Show them because I,
I feel like there's Birkenstocks.
We're not talking about Birkenstocks.
Birkenstocks are ugly too,
by the way.
These are the fully functional dad sandals or mom's sandals there.
Bingo.
Either way.
Yeah.
It's usually the mom sandal.
Actually.
It's the woman who's totally given up.
Oh my God.
I gave up on everything.
Worst,
the terrible Oh beach basics.
Oh,
these are terrible.
There's no excuse.
There's really no excuse.
Like go back to the strap.
All do better.
The terrible.
Absolutely.
Oh my God.
Those are like,
look,
I were orthopedic.
You see like fungus,
nails,
nasty ash on the back here.
Those are like a shacks.
Feet go in there,
but look,
let me show you.
So I'm wearing orthopedics right now,
but they're like,
look,
these are orthopedic for people watching.
I'm lifting into the camera.
You can see they're like ballet flats.
They're nice.
You wouldn't even know.
That's like I give up.
Everything is shut down.
My genital or closed.
Yeah.
Those are terrible man.
You shouldn't sell your vagina's shot.
Yeah.
And I see a lot more dudes in it then I see.
Well I'm like,
Gosh,
I see women with a dude haircuts wearing those.
Yeah,
of course.
That's when you get up off the hair there.
They stopped coloring it.
Yup.
And then they put those on there like,
Hey,
I gotta get kind of getting what I got to get when I'm out there taking care of
life.
Yeah,
it's not.
It's usually couples who were those together and they're like sixties they start
to shut it down sexually.
You'll see some in Denver,
by the way.
Those are total Denver shoes.
I know I didn't want to say that,
but yes,
they are Denver shoes.
Yeah,
of course.
Cause they hire great outdoors.
Patagonia.
I was just like being outside and these are just comfortable and you know the
get the job done.
No,
they don't.
they're terrible dude.
There's nothing in this world that can make me wear those gene.
No,
I promise you as your wife,
I will never wear those.
I will never wear,
those are sandals with a heel.
Those are terrible.
All terrible.
All these are terrible.
Damn it.
I also asked,
I see whenever I see Birkenstocks,
so I always go like,
I just feel like they stink.
Well,
I feel like they do too because the,
they usually are black.
Like if you look at the under the foot of the person,
they're always black because they're worn down.
You sweat in them and that the leather gets some type of right.
The texture of the black.
Usually it's gross.
They look funky.
Yeah.
They looked like they smelled beggars.
They're comfortable.
Right.
Cause a lot of people love him.
People love their birds and I guarantee we're going to get a lot of pushback on
the Berks.
I lived in San Francisco.
A lot of people were,
they're terrible.
Speaking of feet small,
this came in,
my girlfriend and I were having this discussion today.
She said,
the only time I ever washed my feet is when you're in the shower with me and you
make me.
The rest of the time they get washed from the soapy water and down my body.
I on the other hand,
I'm a firm believer in washing of the feet.
Can the Mommy's discussed this James?
Well James,
I'm with your girlfriend.
Great topic.
I don't wash my feet.
You just pee.
Are you soap?
And then it just peace sterile it sterilizes come on,
fuck gotta be so fucking nasty is calling reality.
But I'll tell you what.
I had an ex boyfriend who was very type a very meticulous,
full,
you know,
folded his shirts with the folding board.
Yes.
We didn't last,
obviously I know you didn't last.
I'm a total animal,
but he would insist on washing his feet in the shower.
Really?
And I remember being blown away and I had to pretend like I did that too
regularly.
Like,
Oh yeah,
when you're with him.
I tell the shower too.
I totally wash my feet.
I don't know why.
I mean I get pedicures and then they scrub them like they get in there.
No,
I'd never do well for,
I mean,
unless there's something like there's like I step on tar or something,
you know,
but that's it.
Yeah.
I mean I'm in the pool.
I feel like that washes it and the feet are clean.
I don't have,
I don't have that problem at all.
I never smelled your feet.
Yeah,
I've never like been,
you know,
Ooh kicked out.
Some people do have just naturally funkier feet,
so maybe they need to know my feet are sweaty,
but I feel like they get washed in the shower.
Will you bring up shacks foot?
Oh,
can you want to,
well,
I keep thinking about it.
There was a,
during playoff coverage,
nasty a few days ago,
I think on t.
And.
T they were doing whatever they were doing a remote shot and a or they're at the
game and Shaq took his shoe off and a sock off and showed his size 22 foot.
What kind of dog do you think is on that guy?
I don't know.
It's always been a big point of a discussion about whether it's,
yeah,
it measures up to his enormity cause people,
I think the rumor is that it doesn't,
in other words,
not that it's like teeny tiny,
it's just that it's not in proportion to his size dibs.
This one and no one had sex with Shaquille O'Neal.
Can you let us know now the big question is,
which we've debated hotly on this show is whether or not those things are
correlated,
whether or not hand size is correlated to penile size or an indicator of penile
size.
The foot size.
Um
Oh,
oh.
The big toe is,
look at this thing morphed.
Oof.
Poor guy.
Oh Nasty.
The big toe is what troubles me.
It's just,
it's mashed to the right.
I remember the man wearing shoes that fit when he plays.
No,
no.
It's like a lot of athletes,
particularly in basketball because you are stopping all the time jumping,
running,
and they play these,
you know,
their seasons are 82 games,
seasons and then you practice every day.
A lot of them have really fucked up feet.
It's hard to maintain design shoes to help that.
I don't think it's that the shoe is a problem.
It's just the level of activity.
It's,
it's so much more than,
you know,
you're,
you're constantly pivoting,
jumping,
running,
someone stomping and then,
and then you play a game the next day and the next day and the next day and the
next day.
I remember Jordan's feet were super fucked up.
I saw a photo once he bring it up.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean,
if you want to see it,
yeah.
I kind of do the really fucked up dude.
It's so important to wear good shoes.
Especially the older I get now that I'm into orthopedics.
I really,
I can't,
I can't even wear flats like regular ballet flats.
They really hurt.
Yeah.
I can't do it too.
Since I had a kid,
I just fucked up my whole alignment.
Everything backs all fucked up.
Hips are all messed up.
I remember it was
book,
it was like I had a book.
Uh,
I had a book of it,
of none of his feet,
but of him and they,
he was on the trainer's table.
And I remember the comment from his wife was like,
I can't believe you let them take a picture of that because she didn't,
she was kind of like trying to protect him,
you know?
But I don't see it.
Um,
oh well.
But yeah,
they're there.
It's really common for these athletes have super fun that,
I don't know.
Chicago Bulls,
Michael Jordan.
Well they're all taped up.
You can see that and you can tell there's something resting.
His nails are all jacked up.
Yeah.
They're all fucked up.
I fucked up.
But it's just from,
from being crazy athletes,
you know?
Sure is.
I know what that's like,
unless you sure do.
I had the best thing ever happened to me on the flight home from New York.
From g Dork titties.
Yeah.
I was wearing the gene sweatshirt.
It's like my favorite thing now.
I wear it all the time.
And uh,
the stewardess was,
I'm sorry,
flight attendant.
I got,
sorry.
I'm sorry.
I was such a cisgendered comment.
Yeah,
it was terrible.
She comes up to me and she goes,
oh,
is it Jean or John?
I'm from Montreal.
And I was like,
it's just Jean.
You shouldn't say Sean's Jean.
I couldn't lie to her.
I should have said John,
why couldn't you lie to her?
I just didn't think of it on the spot.
I'm so like,
I'm so earnest.
Yeah.
Real life.
I can't,
I can't be,
I can't lie.
This nice people.
Um,
Jean Jacques Jean,
I really liked that.
I wish I had it recorded.
They're calling this guy the Anti Dad boner.
Okay.
So you know the dad boners obviously really lose their mind and they celebrate
things.
Yeah.
Um,
they just are,
you know,
you can't,
you can't bring a dad Boehner down.
Right.
They just,
they get excited about,
uh,
anything really.
Uh,
oh is this,
this is muted.
Sorry.
Oh my God.
It sounds like an Alco now.
They get excited.
Oh,
so that's it.
Dad boner.
If you're new,
that is a dab on it.
This guy is upset about things.
It's different.
Grumpy Dad.
I been churching farther.
Portholes Oh,
he's on this.
Look at this shit.
You got to ride in the middle of the fucking road
fucking zone.
It's fucking,
oh my
God.
Fuck.
Look how bad that road is.
Terrible.
Okay.
Shit.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
What to do here?
What do I do?
Do I stop?
Do I get it over on your car?
Okay,
my carpet moving.
What the fuck,
dude?
Oh my God.
Fuck a fucking head.
It's like miles.
I feel like I put on,
it's just fucking listen.
Fuck.
Oh fuck.
I'm good.
This is the kind of dad I grew up with.
Yeah,
we'll step.
Dad was more like this.
He was fired up.
That shit.
Okay.
Kicking the dirt like a dog.
Oh,
that's terrible.
That'll fuck your tires up.
Som,
you know.
Oh my God.
This is ridiculous.
He's right.
It is.
It's not cool going.
That's why he prays hair.
That road is just completely battered,
man.
No,
that's no good.
Potholes in my,
okay.
Worth fucking hauled them away.
I'm going to worry is I don't know.
In America.
Piece of shit,
motherfucker.
Yeah.
He's just yelling at the road though.
You don't want even comes out of this fucking road.
They know better.
I've driven on road.
It is unnerving to drive on this didn't fucking war zone.
What the fuck pocket.
That's how I blew out our tire gene.
Really
on the our car.
That's how it happened.
I was on a pothole on sunset up towards the four oh five.
Yeah.
And I took one too fast and the guy says,
look,
I can tell it was a pothole.
They did this to your car.
He told me he showed me.
Yeah.
So I'm going to go slow.
Very cautious.
And it is like an IEP.
Yes.
Fucking terrible
shit.
That's how you're going to be.
I mean it's fucking town hall
probably to be larger at that.
Wow.
Look at that.
That is unbelievable.
The Shit.
This shit
kidding.
It's pretty bad.
My tax paying fucking dollars doing that.
Fuck.
Are they doing,
yeah.
You mentioned you're walking by and seeing that guy making that.
No.
Um,
all right,
so we've got to get to this.
Yeah.
If you're a new listener to the show.
One of our
all time great regulars on this show has been a my father and sometimes my
mother.
And yesterday I had them in here for a little sit down where I got to just talk
to them in general and also catch up on some,
uh,
some show topics and even play some games with them.
Uh,
I can't,
I mean when we are prepping the games,
I was so excited.
I want to sit in here to listen.
But then I thought I'd probably better if I wait until we play it back.
But we also spent the last week with them.
We haven't even gone over that and we got to hear so many wonderful stories from
them about your mom,
Donna.
I can't pronounce words.
He always says
my favorite moment by far.
It was when we were looking for a movie to watch.
And Your Dad's reading off the actors and what does he say,
Tom?
He's like Chris Pratt and Emma Stone and Vincent,
no,
on a free on
shit.
So he goes,
Vince it,
Donna Freon and they near peanut right away.
And I said,
and I don't know what I enjoy him anymore.
He has it care is when he talks and he says something wacky or when you repeat
it perfectly because you do a really good impression of him.
It's like hearing him in Stereo.
He also,
he mispronounces words that I don't like for years.
Right.
He would say a pdf file,
pdf file.
And I would go,
every time you said it,
I would knew what he was trying to say,
but I would go,
what's that?
And he would turn to me like the guy that fucks kids.
Right.
And I would say,
so you mean pedophile?
Oh yeah.
And then you just move on.
And I go,
why do you keep saying it wrong?
I'm like,
what are like,
we're both news junkies,
right?
We both read news watching it.
He'll be like,
did you get here?
This,
uh,
Steve Bannon is doing,
I go,
it's Bannon.
I bet you hear it a hundred times a day.
It's the same guy we put,
it's not a new guy that they mentioned.
Once he sees the word,
he hears it pronounced and then he mispronounces it over and over.
But I think it's because he doesn't have an ear for like music or language.
You have to have an easy ride.
Right.
That's a good point.
You have to be tuned into it and he's just not tuned in.
See they were saying this Gerrard Kushi has gotten like Gerad Jared Kushner.
Yeah.
I'm like,
why do you,
why are you saying Gerad right.
He's getting it.
He's confused with Carmichael.
Yeah.
He's a big Carmichael fan.
It's so bizarre to me.
So,
um,
I think you'll really enjoy,
I'm going to mute our mix just to hear how this starts.
It's audio only.
People will always inevitably go,
why isn't there a video of them?
They're old.
They don't want to be video.
You know,
it's just like when you bust out a camera with mom will be like,
go away.
They could picture what she doesn't want to be on camera.
So,
uh,
it's,
believe me,
the audio is more than sufficient.
Just for a moment,
I'm going to mute us just so you can hear this.
Only because I want you to my dad.
My Dad is a legendary,
a heavy breather too.
So here you go.
MMM,
definitely hear you breathing.
That's for sure.
Can you,
uh,
can you just talk into the microphone mom?
No,
go.
Can you hear me too?
Okay.
There you are.
Let's see.
Holy Shit.
What is up with that?
Just the way of rice.
I mean,
I cannot not do this.
If you're going to go,
that's how he,
okay.
I don't have to,
don't feel bad for him.
I could have a fart.
Why we do this show?
No,
please don't.
I can't help it.
Then you got to leave with,
you have to do that.
Just leave.
You're going to get in a tight space.
Don't do that.
Just get up and leave.
Do it outside.
Seriously.
It'll really ruin this.
Really ruined this.
They'll be able to do it.
Does it smell that bad?
How can you act like you don't know if it smells that bad?
So we had a moments earlier.
You don't know what happened.
I think you forget what you did.
I think it was both the kid down.
Yeah.
I had walked into the Ed just entered the living room like I'm the,
I'm like hitting you.
It smelled like a sewage canal.
And I go,
what the fuck is that?
And he goes,
I just had a little one.
I was like,
and my mom,
I go,
cause she'll think that,
you know,
I go,
just walk towards the living room.
Yeah.
She turned around.
She was like,
oh my God.
Oh yeah.
And I go,
it smells like a sick person.
Yeah.
Like it doesn't,
it doesn't smell right.
I was like,
diarrhea.
Well he farted in the car when we were on the way to the country club and I
smelled it.
I pretend I didn't want to talk about it,
but it was really Ranson.
Oh,
that's like worse napalm.
This was worse.
Yeah.
So I was just telling him,
right,
I,
if you fart here,
this is over.
Well,
this is a small studio and no,
you can't fart.
Yeah.
It's,
it's not like other people's farts.
People don't understand.
It's really not.
Oh my God.
Remember when they farted in front of our nanny,
farted loudly because we were watching a movie and there would be like a scene
where,
you know,
it's like the scene fades out and my mom went
far and I turn and walking past the living room and I was like,
his mouth dropped.
Then I saw her head turn
cause she's like a nice Guatemalan lady.
She hasn't,
she doesn't do that.
No,
there's no way.
no,
no.
Like there's no way.
Oh my mom was mortified when I told her
she heard you fuckers.
Yeah.
To me it smells.
No,
no,
no.
And actually when you catch an infection,
it actually was like a,
like,
it was actually scary how bad that smelled.
Really.
I did.
That had been anybody else.
I mean even as you,
I would tell somebody that you didn't immediately go to a doctor.
I think I'm just,
I'm not even joking.
No,
it's true.
It's funny.
It's funny,
but I told you last night.
Always smell like that.
No,
we all have our own fingerprint in the intestines.
Okay.
Nothing about that.
Smells even remotely normal.
It smells like it.
Smells were really,
really different.
It doesn't snow a normal.
Okay.
I think that would infection.
How do you know you don't have one?
Because I had that normal smell for years.
I live next to you.
Please open the sheets.
I couldn't base.
Do you have a,
Hey,
I'm not picking on where you are.
I think we have a second.
Oh yeah.
Cause you had questions for me because I wanted to,
I wanted to add more ideas.
Yeah.
Okay.
I wonder if,
uh,
no,
you can't hear it.
Does it?
Sometimes you can hear what's going okay.
But I think,
I think we were,
we let we led right into that,
right?
Yeah.
All right.
Christina asked me to ask you how you like your new Bra.
I Dunno.
About what was the experience like?
Oh my God.
I feel like a normal human being.
Can you hear me breathing?
Yes.
It's alarming now,
just so the listeners know your mother,
uh,
I don't know how to put this delicately delicately.
She's big.
Sloppers like me.
Yeah.
But she's been wearing the wrong size bra for her whole life for Sunday.
You knew this already yet.
Cause I bought cars from one big tip monster to another.
I look and I go,
you need to go to Nordstrom.
You need to have a girl measure you because they're trained.
And I,
we got her the right fit and it changed everything.
She looked amazing.
Thank tits up.
I feel like I have actually.
Eh,
how about just sit back,
sit back?
Yeah.
I have him slip and lift it up.
Boom for the booklet.
Really jump up and down.
I am sexy.
Yeah.
I can't even think I'm sexy because what happened was Christina took you and you
were wearing a bra that they all be measured.
You I was wearing all my life.
It's any foreseen.
Yeah.
And I think to be [inaudible] g
um,
first I told the lady,
I said make any sense,
but the truth is it fits me like a glove to me.
Look at this.
Yeah,
we're good.
This,
yeah,
you'll finally got upset because the boobs had employees and passing on Friday.
It looks like a perfect fit to me.
They said perfect fit,
but what it bothers him is that because they fit me,
they're not flying all over and jumping up and down the way he would like.
Is that true?
It is.
I think if you have g yeah,
boobs,
g boobs,
or are really gigantic.
I mean if you go to,
if you Google g boobs,
you'll find,
or you'll find some big books.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think what the,
I thought we got the explanation that that was just the size.
I didn't,
I didn't see that.
Okay,
so Sony did I put B?
well I didn't,
I didn't persist.
I have to go go European Bra sizes versus American.
Okay.
Okay,
so what he got up there,
and these are numbers,
so 28 let's go to cup size.
Screw the numbers.
Okay.
We're talking cops.
Really not bursar or Garth.
You want to get into the real tests?
You got to go there.
The Cup size.
Okay.
Let's see what this says here.
I love it.
Excited.
Those are just pictures.
Is there a ted pictures and look for the conversion.
Okay.
Cupsoles Bra.
I was kind of brought her,
maybe this will be it.
Try and make sense to him,
you know.
Hey,
can you pause for a second?
Yeah.
I think he was upset because he felt jipped right.
Cause we came home and I texted her mother,
Hey,
what a top dog.
Think about your new boobs.
Yeah.
And she texted me back.
He's upset.
He's disappointed.
Yeah.
And then you said,
I said it's because he wants them spelling out.
Right.
So the,
the,
the bra that's an ill fitting is exciting to him because tests are falling out
of it.
So he feels gypped.
Like he feels like we,
we snuck in.
Yeah.
And ruined his,
his tip pleasure.
Yeah.
True.
Interesting.
Okay.
If I am at three,
so g here.
Yeah.
It was tripled the USA say,
mom,
can you show me how those big tits,
Raj,
how the deep big debts far.
Yeah.
That's unfair.
Tommy,
can you,
can you make them?
Yeah.
What is you talking about?
People want it.
People want to know if you can show them how those big tits fart.
Okay.
I would think in this serious,
yeah.
Okay.
Let's go to
you went to far?
Yeah.
Oh,
he's in the song.
He was going to be hell or what?
Yeah.
Um,
this was a song that we sing all the time.
Yeah.
We saw you get in the car and then she came up with her version.
Uh,
can you,
oh,
d one to five.
We talking real far.
Far,
far,
far as a,
as this far right.
Really
because the original song is do you run a park?
Can you really?
Can you really fuck
do you one to five.
One to five.
Five,
five.
Oh
Wow.
Really good.
I really hope that at least maybe one of our genius musical listeners can do
something with that.
Create a real tune out of that.
I think it's already working.
It's already happening.
Oh No.
That was the one you add this morning in the bathroom.
You also,
both of you forward in front of our nanny.
That would be less embarrassing to talk about that you did,
but hers,
hers,
any dust,
I suppose,
higher than mine.
That was a really sad,
I got to study this,
this cup size chart.
What did you see?
Did you do it says right here,
Europe,
g triple D
or e or actually if they are UK.
Yeah,
if it was UK,
Gee,
it'd be an f.
But that makes sense.
So you're,
I am at three.
Paul D.
Yeah.
So that makes sense.
That makes total sense.
Better.
We were doing everything wrong because I was using city for
30 yeah.
And then you drove me to 30 was a little tight and that was good.
It stretches a little bit.
So what is it,
what is your disappointment in these bars?
Because he's just kind of flattened everything out.
No cleavage sweats.
I like lay beach.
I like how each and Bush was the first time he's a Bush,
but cleavage cleavage.
I've always,
I was raised on Clay Beach.
Okay.
Yeah.
When I was,
when I was,
you know,
a good little Catholic boy going to move.
You didn't have all,
you have habits clean each.
Yeah.
Most.
Okay.
So
that's not,
that's not pushed together cleavage.
That's,
see,
so that's what it was.
Yeah.
The comfort provided by the good fitting Bra and dominates what he likes us
clover.
Yeah.
Well here's your,
here's the deal.
You can also buy a bra that fits and that creates cleavage.
But your mother was insistent upon not buying a bra that was too sexy.
So we got our eyebrows that were in a comfort zone,
but she didn't want like the Sassy ones is one.
I'm trying to say.
I tried,
believe me,
I wanted to,
I wanted to do this for your dad more than anybody.
Like I wanted your mom to come back with a little Sassy,
tattooed.
She was the first person to ever say tits don't fart.
She answered right?
She was like,
do you still buy?
They still fine.
Most people don't push back on that.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Do you want me to get him a smaller,
so the thing pops out a little bit smaller and kind of little claim each.
I like to run on,
you pay for the boob lift so you don't need a boob lift.
You've got great boobs.
No.
Okay.
You just have the wrong bra.
Yes.
All that they have,
they make pushup bras.
They make bras to put them together.
So this one just flattened everything out.
It seems like he's making his case.
I you gotta respect the case.
That's the most stupid case I ever hear.
Hello.
Look at this.
I can jump up and down and nothing move.
Well,
I guess you've got to look at it from your point of view.
If you really look at it.
Perfect.
I know,
but if you're comfortable,
but it's still likely beach,
you need to find a different woman that,
oh,
how's the trip been for you so far?
The best.
It's been fantastic.
Honestly,
the best repair ever in every sense.
Thrown the minute that we got in the playing and that is spoiling little bed
that yeah,
I am talking or no,
is it my turn?
There's,
there's uh,
this Mike come right here.
Right?
Mute his mic.
Really?
Yeah.
The breathing is overwhelming to me.
I,
I feel like he has to go to the doc.
This is what makes every phone call is like,
yeah.
And getting more because I'll be down there.
It is.
Yeah.
Yes,
I did.
Well then we come here.
I got aliases.
Absolutely.
To die for it's ratios.
Perfect.
Beautiful boy.
However,
if I am doing,
I will take a DNA test.
I know doing like that too.
Is it starting to look so much like his mind?
I don't see he really is a perfect kid
and so intelligent.
He observed the sense we have to bring up colon.
I'm muted your mic and see our dead.
We have to bring up one point that that Alex gave me a lot of kisses and I think
you got your head like grandparent battles.
Who could?
Ellis would give him the most kisses
first kiss.
Was it yesterday or today?
I can't remember now.
I'm about 25 kisses to your two or three right now.
Know that that's fact.
I mean,
we've done it with facts,
not carrots.
I have to admit,
you know,
and,
and I think that,
I don't know why to me I'm convinced is because I think it's confidence.
I told you I've got my theory on it.
I think he confuses your five.
We're doing,
he looks at I like and he says,
no,
no Tom,
he has a beard.
It doesn't cause opinion.
I'm clean shaven every day of my life.
Um,
and that's true.
It's true.
So it's,
it's really,
I think it's the,
the vibes vibes.
Maybe eight that I soak hot.
Yeah.
Just occurred to me is that your dad was wearing the same outfit the whole week.
Like he didn't change.
He came over,
he was wearing Khakis that were too big for him.
He's lost weight once.
Right.
But I'm saying he were oversized Khakis with a belt and then the Khakis will
come up over the belt because it was too,
too big.
But he didn't want,
he didn't want to buy pants of fit.
No.
He went where the big pants and then he laid on the couch.
Murray,
he was laying there watching that movie and two buttons came on done.
And then his who,
she was hanging out,
his stomach was hanging out.
Yeah.
It's so funny.
He hates being comfortable.
He was comfortable.
You've got that wrong.
He says he's comfortable.
I am comfortable.
He came over,
it was like a chill day and just laid in Khakis and a button down.
And that was his comfort.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
A belt.
Yeah,
I'd loafers.
That's his comfort.
It makes me so uncomfortable watching t shirt and sweatpants.
Yeah.
I can't do it.
I get home.
I don't have to take everything off right away.
Me
Too.
I'm the same way.
I walk around in my boxers right in front of the nanny too.
What else gets fuck out of here?
Tommy's right.
You go in with,
you hesitate when you go in.
You're almost looking for protection.
I am trying.
No,
I go in with full confidence.
I'm going to get it.
Yes.
Yeah,
that's true.
Let me ask you this.
Recently,
you called me from the Orlando Airport.
Do you remember this?
Oh yeah.
That was really,
I know people would want to hear about this.
You called me from the Orlando Airport from the same restroom stall
about,
you know,
it was probably almost,
almost 20 years ago when I had,
I did the little little accident in the my pants and they were aligned to
airport and I had to leave my underwear in the stall.
Well,
what I did was the other day,
a little time,
I went back and revisited.
Wow.
The location took a picture of the stall.
You really,
I did.
I haven't timed it.
And you know,
they've,
they've made some modifications.
The,
the uh,
they all make,
all the places have bigger handicap stalls now it's the law,
you know,
but that spot is still there and uh,
went in and you know,
it's just kind of relived that moment,
you know,
some people message me that they're at the Orlando airport and they want to know
what stall it happening so they can go visit.
It now needs
to be terminal side.
It's on the,
it's on,
be on here.
If you come up out of be baggage claim,
maybe they want to know what it is.
So they come up out of baggage claim B and go to the right before you,
there it is.
He,
through his underwear there had to leave the underwear and even had shit on his
pants.
But guess what?
He just happened to him again and his office.
What?
Why don't you tell them?
Oh,
I told you about that when I had a little fumble in the office recently.
Yeah.
What happened?
I couldn't get,
I was,
I was heading in there.
I thought I had perfect timing,
but I had,
you know,
at some suits they had that other book.
Yeah.
And I had trouble getting that undone and before I could make the turn and
dropped the drawers,
I had a little foam ball.
How much?
Not a lot,
but enough to go in the wrong places where I had to actually.
Did you go home now?
What I did was I just threw the underwear where I cleaned up in there and a,
I just wear my suit pants.
No underwear,
no underwear.
Was it on your legs and stuff too?
No,
it was a little bit on the leg,
but I got that off
mostly on cheeks.
This is,
and it was a stinker too.
I mean,
yeah,
if that's any indication of what comes out,
I'm sure it was a stinker,
but uh,
you know,
I thought about going home man and change it,
but I figured pretty much got everything done with that one.
But I think he's been out of talking to the mic.
No,
no,
I'm paying,
I'm in battles.
Why are you embarrassed?
Because this is disgusting.
It's just part of life.
I'm kind of flights reality.
I needed Ponson yet floating.
I said,
what do you do when you're done the way I left it in my office.
Oh No,
not in the lunch room.
I said to in the bench where you throw your hook.
He said,
so why are they killing?
People are coming in as a so you want where you have your hand towel.
So I just throw it in there and people put ant dials and adopt.
Nobody's going to see it.
I mean,
paper towels,
paper towels.
I felt good though after I did that though.
Let me know.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't.
He live on the air.
His office a good sound.
Yeah.
Far.
You know that um,
there's this couple,
a mother and son that they got married.
Yeah.
Can you imagine marrying your one of your children?
No.
That's a joke.
No,
no,
no.
[inaudible] I know they just got arrested.
Waiting.
What part?
Um,
I forget.
I'm your mom and you're my son and I if falling in love with him,
he said,
are you really?
I said,
yes,
I am.
He's thinking,
you know what?
I was scared to let you know too.
I am too.
They're both consenting adults.
If,
if it comes down to it,
you know,
it's just like the gays.
They're there,
you know,
as long as they're over 18 everything's fine.
What?
Yeah.
Well they want to do jail time for 18 months.
So I guess,
you know,
I have never heard a story like this in my life.
I know.
Will you ever date your mom?
And he said,
well,
you did your son.
And I said,
y'all,
it's truth.
Yes,
I would.
Because 19 years you're the best thing that ever happened to me and I really
want to be with you.
Right.
God
grow.
So these hit no girl to this.
This is,
it's unconceivable.
Yeah,
that's pretty bad.
Yeah.
What is sick minds?
We used to be scared of the teacher with the student.
I know now as a mother with a son,
mother,
and the son.
The first approach was actually me and I'm like,
what happened?
We were hanging out and you know,
just talking.
And I was just loud.
I looked at her and she looked at me and I just,
I kissed her.
Was a real kiss.
Did he knew what his mother?
Of course,
of course you notes it's just mother.
Yeah,
I was a real kiss.
Oh,
let me know.
See it.
I know.
I'm gonna know.
It's got to be a joke.
I know.
It's real.
They got arrested.
There was an,
then we followed up on the story.
They got arrested.
I can not believe this is true.
Would you marry your grandson?
I
want is going more than crazy now.
Yeah.
No,
I'm not kidding you.
This is to,
yes,
we're getting too extreme craziness.
Yeah.
You'll know.
Tomorrow you're going to find out your fire.
Really exciting.
Isis.
Oh really?
Dad?
Yeah,
you're an isis.
Tell him that's one organization.
I would never even joke being apart.
Um,
the,
uh,
a lot of the listeners want to hear,
what'd you rather it's with you guys.
Okay.
They want to hear what would you rather,
okay.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh,
wrong button.
Not Related Farther.
My now here,
the breathing.
Yeah,
it's a lot.
I had to park.
You hear that?
Yeah.
Drink
the top layer.
Chunky
urine homeless men.
There's times by my buttons
or sex with your sister.
Grandmother walks in on you masturbating.
Never have another orgasm.
It's trying to play.
Would you rather?
Okay.
I'm assuming you've never played this before.
So what happens is I present two scenarios
right down.
Is that coming from your recording?
It's coming from,
um,
anyways,
what,
what happens is I present to you two scenarios.
Okay?
And you have to pick one.
In other words,
it's two things that are undesirable.
So have to pick one.
Yeah,
that's the game.
It's just like,
it's just a logic game.
And then you explain why.
So in other words,
what I said,
uh,
would you rather,
you know,
eat nothing but uh,
marshmallows or only get to sleep 30 minutes at a time?
Those are both things you don't want to do,
but you go,
I would take the marshmallows because I,
I could deal with eating that.
I have to get like you have to explain why you chose one or the other.
Okay.
So the first one that came in for you was Charo.
Would you rather eat nothing but vegetables and you can visit casinos as much as
you want or no casinos,
but you can eat what you really need to finish
that question.
Really eat only vegetables that visit casinos as much as I really 100% that's
how much that means to you is that I have no doubts,
no doubts.
That's what she would say.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That would mean breakfast,
lunch and dinner.
Nothing but the vegetables.
You would do it 100% I cannot believe this.
[inaudible] see,
I think that you're saying that,
but the reality would be too hard.
Not really nothing.
That's how much you love casino.
My Gosh.
I'm so they could do a stupid machines.
And you're so good at it.
Yeah,
I leave it on.
No,
no.
Nobody knows what it ain't even about,
about how good she is at taking these casinos to the cleaners.
Oh my gosh.
He does.
She cleans the,
uh,
she cleans them all right.
Yeah,
I cleaned,
I cleaned my,
what she does is she's empty as I'm out.
Actually she fills them up with so much money,
they to be taken
out and a one,
what was that?
But the fact is your mother won't eat anything that is grown from the ground.
And that includes,
I made strawberry shortcake for dinner last night for dessert.
She wouldn't even eat a strawberry.
Like your mother won't even touch a Brussel sprout even if it's covered in a
delicious sauce.
And she's super petite.
Tiny.
It's like 105 pounds.
Oh my gosh.
But all she eats is cookies,
sweets,
bread with butter.
It's unbelievable.
She's alive and like flying colors.
Yeah,
that's bananas.
But that's why I thought that was really crazy to ask her cause she loves,
I know I thought to cause that's what I'm saying though,
the reality,
I don't think she's facing the reality on that one.
It's just that she really does love casinos.
Right.
My mom,
by the way,
if you're thinking poker player,
just slots,
men,
just penny slots changing pennies.
Okay.
So God is,
what is the thrill though?
Cause hearing,
Ding,
Ding.
When you see a wind a little bit,
not because I never went a little bit of weight.
So when,
where's the payoff?
Number one,
I see machines that have been based on this is going to be,
do you ever get a payout?
Yes.
Well she gave me $1,000 to came back to the Rhombus thousand dollars.
When was that?
Could a year or so ago.
When was she goes a lot.
One was Clinton president.
Let me see.
It wasn't most excited seeing the office and it was at 1,001 payout.
Yes.
That's exciting.
How much were you betting on that?
Because my problem with you as somebody that doesn't do it a lot,
cause I always think you bet too little.
No,
I have race my bed.
He says you used to last a dollars night.
I was working some casinos.
I think I told you.
And as I'm walking to my,
to the showroom,
I walked by the high dollar slots.
So He's putting in a $20 thing and he'd spin spin spin and two out of the three
times I did that,
I won first time,
$300 the next time $700 and then the will the nice time I lost,
but so yeah.
Then where to sell $7 yeah,
I spent 60 but again,
after I did that,
I just my eye,
in other words,
I played for 30 seconds.
Do you guys want to go put some money to save?
You went,
yeah.
Yeah.
For me it's my new,
yeah.
Yeah.
I get a rash.
I'd have to have my own juice,
my,
my cigarette,
nice slot machine that is going to pay me.
I don't like people around,
by the way,
on this trip.
Okay.
I don't understand that.
She has not spoken.
Not There's no casinos in here,
but usually I thought you'd like your evening cigarette and not when she's out
of town,
but at home.
Don't you have an evening?
I haven't even,
I haven't even been thinking about it,
but the interesting to me is we are no dad.
Would you rather go on all the cruises you want,
but it's only to Vietnam or you have to wear tight jeans and loose tee shirts
every day or you cruise wherever you want to.
People that don't know,
you have to understand a couple of things.
He's a Vietnam vet.
Uh,
he hates everything,
like Asian cuisine,
all that.
And it's the whole world,
I think as a byproduct of being more there and also hates informal where only,
yeah.
Hates him.
Hates them.
He hates wearing a shirt that's not collared.
Yeah.
Uh,
tight jeans and loose tee shirts and cruise wherever I want.
Really?
You wear jeans every day?
Cruise or whatever I want.
Yeah.
Versus going to Vietnam.
I get that.
Get old pretty fast.
But he let me tell you.
I bet.
Yeah.
No,
I'll take the tight jeans and that.
Really?
Yeah.
You never wear jeans?
I know.
I don't wear jeans.
I do have my Khakis on right now.
I assistance they gave me,
uh,
genes for Christmas as a joke.
No,
they thought I ordered them for me.
Really Nice ones.
Really?
Yeah,
of course are nice.
they're very,
I'm saying like there's,
I think there's nice designer jeans that actually fit these had like,
like,
no,
I mean if I,
if I go,
if I go shooting next time I go clay pigeon shooting and I might wear them like,
really?
Yeah.
I saw you in a pair of jeans and black sneakers and I thought I looked really
good actually.
He looks great in that.
That's what I'm saying.
They look good on you.
Yeah,
but that's an easy,
that's an easy one for me really.
I think you would get so annoyed every day I go to cruise anywhere.
I want to
love
you have to wear it.
I know I can cruise wherever I want.
Yeah.
And get tight jeans.
I don't know what that boxers and you'd have to ask me to help you pull up the
zipper.
That's true.
Yeah.
Charles,
would you rather be retarded or you have to drive on the freeway.
Okay.
Tito sinking.
Really?
I can't,
I can't
that people would feel sorry for me.
He's convinced that every car in the freeway,
first of all,
this happened one time.
We're coming back from the Jacksonville's.
We had the male clinic thing.
I,
I am.
I was.
I did.
I got frustrated.
So she's going to follow.
I'm following you following me.
Okay.
Oh boy.
She gets behind.
She gets by a truck and this is on 95 going south on a truck,
getting behind the truck.
It's 45 and a seven I think.
Safe.
She felt so he did.
I want to tell you what he did.
He pulled out his card.
So I said,
oh my God,
something happened to your father.
So I needed to,
when they get out and say,
well,
what happened at,
he
told me,
he made me shake.
I am here.
I'm in this breezeway for first time it scared to death.
Jesus.
I wanted a divorce rate right?
That moment I couldn't because I was in this breezeway.
Here we are 45 and a 70.
I said,
well then,
then Tom,
get in front of me and I have 4,500 follow you
to what?
How did you make this drive?
Uh,
he had to drive.
It's lower than I have to spend a little bit.
And how slow did you drive from Jacksonville?
All we were under weight.
We got,
I don't know how many thousand cars are on the expressway that day.
We got passed by every one of them.
Stayed in the right lane,
stay in the right lane,
and he went after me,
went up to 50 excuse me,
drove 50 are you being serious?
It took you seven hours to get back and took us a long time.
You realize how slow that is.
Your mother has a crippling fear of the freeway and you know that.
She was like,
we were driving around our neighborhoods and and she's like,
Oh,
I'd love to live in California except that I can't take the freeway for those
outside of California,
a substitute highway for a freeway.
People think that's a,
I know.
You're like,
what is that same thing?
They call it a freeway out here.
Yeah,
but your mother was like,
this is an ideal place.
Everything's great.
Everything's perfect,
but I have to take a freeway.
I'm like,
well,
you can get over that rather be retarded.
I saw every make and model of car,
every truck and I asked him to ask me to forgive him when we got to now don't
you feel that's a little ridiculous that you should,
you should because it's such a,
a fear of this I cannot describe to you really don't mean it's horrendous.
You just scared when you're out there.
Really.
Your
so different thought.
Well,
okay,
you're going to be retarded then.
That's fine.
Would you rather be retarded or you can only eat Asian food.
You're not retarded.
He wouldn't need a good one.
How do you define Asian food
worlds?
Like food from
China,
Cambodia,
Vietnam,
Singapore,
Korea.
Just you know,
the Asian world.
That's a tough one because there's some things in Asia that I could eat.
Like duck.
Yeah,
noodles,
right?
Sure.
So if I could have a selection of the menu,
yeah,
I would do the Asian food.
Okay.
And if,
if,
if you have to dictate what Asian food it is,
if somebody says you have GE,
whatever we're going to give you.
Yeah,
I'd go the retarded.
Really?
You'd be mentally retarded because I wouldn't want it.
No.
On.
I'm not going to eat dog.
Okay.
I'm not eating dog and Duck Ma.
That's another Vietnamese thing.
I'm not going to eat that.
Okay.
There's some things that I just would never eat.
So you choose.
So if I have a choice of Asian food?
Yeah,
like nobody's going to give you a choice.
The question I asked.
Okay,
so let's say there's no choice.
It's just whatever Asian food is given to,
you know,
I'd go retarded.
No,
I'm not eating dogs.
I love dogs too much.
Okay,
okay.
I mean in Korea,
yes.
One time I was there they said the street meat was dog eat it.
But it's not like he thinks it's on like it's a great,
nice run.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's cool.
Yeah.
I mean it's not like all Asian cultures eat dogs.
A lot of them do.
Okay.
I mean it's really prevalent in China.
Only parts of China he wants,
he has to make a selection on his foot.
Can you imagine what kind of punishment is that?
I got another good one for your mom.
Would you rather sleep in a cold cold room?
Ac is on like 65 oh my gosh.
Are you can,
you can have all the sweets you want or you never have any sweets again,
but you can sleep in any temperature you like.
I like,
I know that's a good one.
This is from Christina.
Christina,
she's good at this shit to be not that extreme.
Extremes are the fun when it's when it's good,
so it's like I never can you switch with something so you'd know suites,
you take temperature?
No,
you just be,
you just have to bundle up a lot in bed sweaters and blankets and the
temperature is 65 and I can put all the blankets I want.
I mean,
yeah,
you can put blankets on.
Yeah,
of course.
Okay.
If I can wrap up myself in 50 blankets I used to,
I keep that and give my switch,
but every time you walk in the room it's freezing.
That's fine.
But I am going to be prepared to yes.
Be in boots and socks and a blanket and a jacket and holy and good one for you.
Okay.
Would you rather dad,
you work in a gay bar as a server topless,
so you wear pants but no shirt and the guys come up to you and they're allowed
to sexually harass you.
Like they,
they pinch your nipples every time they walked by and they scratch your chest or
you're married to Nancy Pelosi for a year.
I'll take the gape gay bar thing.
Uh,
no problem.
Really.
Absolutely.
That's how much you can't stand her.
I just,
you know,
don't get me going on that path.
Okay.
The gay and gay,
I mean,
they're nice,
okay guys,
but every time they walk by
I could handle that.
I can handle that actually.
I think he's excited.
What it is.
Excellent too.
I don't know if I could a lot of attention.
I don't think I can handle the Nancy Polosi politics for a year.
For a year now.
What if the ratio is one month of Nancy Pelosi or a year in the gay bar?
I could do one month of Betsy below.
You could do that as a wife.
You have to wake up next to her.
You have to have breakfast.
Whether you have to have dinner with or you don't have to have a lunch with her,
you have to have sex with her.
Okay.
Mom twice.
I can't imagine myself having sex.
She does have very,
you are,
she's been,
she does have,
she's got a nice set of lungs.
Okay.
Yeah.
And she's had multiple face lifts and she's had some work done.
She's had some work done.
Uh,
I could prop back again.
I can try to win,
but win her over to my arguments,
which would be fruitless course.
Since I never went in the arguments with your mother,
let's say,
don't you take a mouse with ted?
I can probably handle a month when Nancy Pelosi,
that's going to cost him his marriage right now.
Yeah.
Do you know Nancy Polosi is?
Yes.
Do you think that's not the point,
right.
He will take care of that.
Huge.
She sounds it should
B,
I wouldn't take any woman older than your mother,
no matter what the answer is within the game.
As part of the game.
Yeah.
Well,
in the game,
what does he go with the gays?
They were so nice.
And the,
he loved to be pinching it.
It's on horizon
one more for you.
Okay.
Would you rather have four penises on your forehead?
Ah,
for 10 nipples for fingers.
I Don.
I cannot pick either one.
Yeah,
you have to for penis in my four zero little penises are hanging from your,
that has no possibility in four of them.
No.
All it is is is a little like I am a woman.
I know,
but they're just hanging from your forehead.
High boredom or what it meets.
One of your fingers is a nipple.
Every finger.
I mean your fire would be really excited to have 10 nipple fingertips.
Think about how hard it would be to do everyday things cause you don't have
fingers.
You have nipples.
Oh he stood the fingers.
Yeah.
You have used nipples on your hands.
Kind of cute.
It's kind of cute.
I kept the nipples.
Really?
Yeah.
I would do dicks dickheads right on my forehead.
I wear a hat like you got on right now and cover them.
Well I don't know if you're allowed to cover him in stipulate that.
I know,
but it comes up.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
I think I would just keep it for a little decks on my forehead.
Ah,
yeah.
I would do dicks.
It'd be,
it'd be funny because I have to use my hands.
My point.
Yeah.
The hands are really important.
You took care of,
you need hands,
right?
Yeah.
Plus I just like make a living being like the the dick head girl on Instagram.
And I get like a million followers and maybe when you get really angry they
stand up or something.
Cool.
Yeah.
Tell your little seed faith with for penis hanging on my forehead.
That's not that bad.
It's a good conversation starter or you out of your mind.
Oh,
people would be like,
what's going on there?
And you have nothing.
I have a penis on my forehead when I can do the same thing with my little things
and I have the same interest in conversation.
Definitely the,
the,
the nipples in it was really,
yeah,
it kind of killed.
They might.
What would you choose?
Oh,
the nipples really well,
sure.
How come?
The thing is I see it as the nipples as fingers actually make doing so many
tasks,
almost impossible.
Whereas the penis on your forehead,
it doesn't keep you from doing anything.
It's just aesthetically awkward.
Right.
In other words,
you still have your full range of everything you can do with your hand.
Hod that covers the Naples,
uh,
the peanuts.
That's a good question.
No,
I think they have to be out,
but they're just aesthetically weird.
No,
aesthetically monster.
Nowhere.
Why would you choose the nipples?
I think for pain.
This is from your forehead.
Just,
it's so an comprehensible that you wouldn't feel like going out in society to
begin with.
I only wouldn't care what you could do.
You Really,
oh,
cause you think people would be,
you'd be that much of an outcast and you match.
I think you would be filling your mind that you would,
you would make the cover of ad magazine.
Okay.
Yeah.
I do.
The only good thing I do will have your own TV show.
Yeah,
that's true.
Do you think they would discriminate against you?
Oh No.
They wouldn't discriminate against me.
They did.
You know they would and then you know what happens if some of them work and some
of them don't.
Okay.
Then you got a reel that's called the ups and downs.
Close that down to anything.
But what if some of them go up and saw them?
Neither one works.
Yeah.
How do you know that?
Because he says that the same country and they're true.
He got so excited
about his job,
the ups and the downs.
Okay.
What'd they pee?
The DEX.
Could you pee out of your forehead decks?
No,
I don't think so.
Not In my mind.
Could you jerk off your forehead decks and picture?
I used to picture them like a growth almost,
you know?
Yes,
I did.
I didn't picture then is functional pieces,
but that's a,
that's a whole other level if it now,
cause I might choose finger nipples if they were Dixit peed and Jack Ejaculate,
you know,
because that's a way more debilitating than you'd have come in your eyes and pee
on her forehead.
And it's true.
It's a good point.
And what are their balls?
Tailwater sticks.
I really wish my parents had thought like you do right now and asked you about
that.
What about the balls so seriously?
There's no balls.
Oh,
okay.
It's just too it.
You don't have a penis.
Barely one during that time,
barely won some jokes for you.
Good luck jokes.
Revisiting the infamous a blonde jokes.
Oh my God.
I found a new page of them.
I think they've taken this one or two repeats,
but mostly knew this blew me away.
I knew how he would react.
I was surprised at her reaction.
Really?
Yes.
I'm excited to hear these.
You do it for blonde throws a grenade at you?
Uh,
I don't know.
Pull the pin and throw it back.
What do you call it when a blonde dyes their hair brunette.
I Dunno.
Artificial intelligence.
That's a good one.
Why did the blonde get fired from the banana plantation?
I give up because she threw out all the bent ones.
That's a good one.
I tell you one.
Sure.
Okay.
He's so excited.
They love these stupid jokes.
Do you think that they're just simple people?
Why?
I know why your mother mother's laughing because I'm sure as a non native
English speaker like you can put two and two together and you can understand
those jokes.
Yeah,
it's a very elementary,
you know,
for a non native speaker for your dad,
it's just,
that's just as jam dude.
He just,
he loves stupid people jokes,
you know.
So this blog is sitting in it
bar in Chicago.
I bet you Chicago is immaterial to the joke.
What do you think?
Well he's told me this,
Joe Eddie told it on our show already.
Oh No.
Watching the five o'clock news and the guy sits down next to her.
I remember this.
Yeah.
Oh God says looking up to TV and there's a guy on the ledge of a building
getting ready to jog emails and the guy says to the woman,
I bet you he jumps.
And the woman says,
you're on.
I bet you he doesn't.
Well the guy jumped and the woman says,
well I guess I owe you a drink.
And he says,
sorry,
I really can't take your money cause I saw it on the four o'clock news that he
jumped.
She says I saw it too,
but I thought he changed his mind.
That's pretty funny.
Can you tell me that one before?
Yeah,
I got another one.
If you want it.
Is it going to be one I've heard before?
Of course.
About the woman in the airplane going to London.
Yeah.
I mean you've already told me this at least 25 times.
Okay.
You have to find the middle then.
What do you call a smart blonde?
I give up a golden retriever.
I love,
I like,
how are you get I give up.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that you just play.
You go along for the ride.
Yeah.
What?
What I do?
I give up.
I don't know.
Searching.
He's like,
yeah,
you don't need to,
it's not a guessing.
I think he tries on one of these.
The joke about the the Poli Sci captain?
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
You probably want me to come up with some new jokes eventually.
It would be nice.
I'll work on that.
Um,
how do you make a blonde laugh on Saturday?
I give up.
Tell her a joke on Wednesday.
Yeah.
Like I tell you,
she gets to go.
How?
How you make,
how play along.
I give up.
Okay.
It's funny.
I have to like that one.
You liked that one?
Like that one.
I don't think we need to do
play that.
Would you rather?
I think they already decided and they are retarded.
That's what I get from this.
That's fine.
You know what?
That is funny.
That is,
why can't blondes count until 70?
I can't think of a reason because 69 is a bit of a mouthful.
Yeah.
You stay.
Mom wasn't getting no.
Your mom does it and I liked that one.
Your mom has no idea what that no idea.
Like,
I don't know.
No idea.
I got to high numbers.
Yeah.
Um,
let's see.
I didn't,
why did the blind stare at a frozen orange juice can for two hours?
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I couldn't come up with an answer for that in a million years
because it said concentrate.
Oh,
that's great.
Oh my God,
Arius.
That's actually funny.
That's really funny.
I like to use,
I would laugh at that joke like I don't,
I don't know.
I didn't have full after.
I can't imagine laughing out loud at that.
Okay.
I mean,
seriously.
I didn't think there were people who thought this shit was really fun to
setting.
To me.
Somebody would laugh out loud.
I know it's an lol for some people,
but some people like dad boner jokes do like this is just,
this is like so silly jokes you would read on the back of a bubble gum for most
it's worthless.
Yeah.
You Go,
you kind of smirk at it like,
oh,
that's clever.
The concentrate joke about,
that's a solid joke to laugh out loud that hard at it.
Yeah.
It's frustrating.
And then you think,
doesn't it make you wonder like when they come watch you perform,
like what?
What are,
they never left this heart.
They've never left the card at anything,
but what are they thinking of your act if they think this shit's hilarious.
Yeah.
Well they don't have at it.
They go,
what happens is I've,
I've learned about him.
He gauges all,
he cares about his audience response.
He has no connection to what I'm doing.
Oh boy.
He just goes,
they really liked that are like,
wow,
you really had them going right.
He's entertained by the audience being in agreement.
He doesn't,
uh,
yeah,
I got it.
Wow.
It's astounding.
And I think it's also very telling that his absolute favorite,
favorite,
favorite by far think of mine is my most undeveloped,
my elementary level stand up if you will.
Should I first thing right?
Your first year.
First job.
First jokes.
Oh,
more?
Yeah.
Like you said please.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm basically a,
you know,
a new comic and um,
every night I'm trying to make this stuff work.
It's very kind of laid out,
joke,
joke.
He's like,
that's,
that's my favorite.
I didn't have anything past that.
He's like,
yeah,
but you know,
on that first one,
that's all he ever talks about.
Isn't it amazing?
Do you think that,
do you think that we'll ever see Ellis who he is?
Do you know what I mean?
Like,
do you think that every,
every generation supposably yeah.
Gets better at this kind of stuff?
Emotions.
Oh,
right.
Acknowledging people,
but we'll have our faults.
But do you think that we'll be able to see our child,
like truly see and hear and much more than we were seeing then our parents?
Yeah.
Isn't that amazing?
It is,
but you wonder what do they think of you?
Like what did they think of us?
What do they think of anything?
It actually,
I feel it inside of me when he's still brings that up.
That first album.
Yeah.
Like I'm still like,
because he doesn't appreciate the fact that you've evolved as a comic.
You're,
you're more complex now.
Remember lies.
He'll go,
you remember when on?
I'm like,
Dude,
stop bringing that up.
All right.
Stop saying that when it was really funny.
He says it like it,
like talking about one of these jokes,
the right side of that guy.
You,
you're really good dad.
I'm like,
okay.
Anyways,
yeah.
I just never changes.
And the other thing is that it's repeated.
In other words,
he'll point the same thing out to me a hundred times about that.
Yeah.
The next week he might go,
where are you going?
I'm going to a Tucson.
Hi.
Yeah,
good.
we're on that.
A Minnesota thing.
He did.
Or You said to the guy,
what's your name like?
Yeah.
You keep telling me that.
You keep saying that to me.
He's just like,
he's living his own moments over and over.
You know?
Like he's only in his reality.
Like he can't,
that's what I'm saying.
He can't even see what's happening and changing.
It's so fun.
It's so fascinating.
Humans are so fascinating to me.
Yeah.
Walk.
Yeah,
I love it.
That was best one surprise.
Blondes have Tgi F on their shoes.
Yeah.
I didn't even know what to say.
EGF on their shoes.
Toes go in first.
Oh,
I love law jokes.
What's the difference between a blonde and a mosquito?
MMM.
I have no idea.
My mosquito stop sucking when you smack it.
Your mom doesn't know what that means.
No clue.
None.
Oh,
these are ones I haven't heard.
I like all these.
Yeah,
I could see the joy in your face.
Oh,
this is,
this is really,
this has been a great trip going out here.
Just highlight of the highlight of the trip.
I know.
I've never seen somebody enjoy street jokes as much as you.
He loves him.
I know.
It's crazy.
Jokes.
Blonde jokes,
street jokes,
three jokes.
Yeah,
I do.
He loves them.
Yeah.
And then once he learned them,
he repeat them.
Repeat at repair and
another one and another one.
Um,
you know,
I'm offended by it.
Why does a blonde wear a tight skirt?
I don't know.
To keep her legs closed.
She got down.
She heard about the two blondes that driving down I 75.
Oh my God.
He's telling me that 100 times.
What's the punchline?
I'll just let it,
he's gonna say it anyways.
I'm offended.
This is a very blonde phobic.
How offended are you?
Very deeply.
I wish you guys would respect my hair color.
Yeah,
because you're thinking about filing suit.
I like to,
Oh,
how about blogging?
I like to block my feelings.
I like to tweet about it.
I like to demand that your dad get fired from his job for laughing at these
offensive jokes.
I'm very affinity.
That's very progressive of dare you.
How dare you not agree with me and my point of view and stereotype is blonds
like that Dario
and they saw a sign that said clean restrooms head but time they got to Miami.
They clean hundred and 50.
Yeah,
I will put,
um,
what does it call when a blonde blows breaking is another blonde here.
I give up wind tunnel.
I'm not supposed to say that.
I know.
I don't know.
See how you he goes,
I'm not supposed to say that.
I know.
I don't know.
Why would that be a joke?
What's it called when the blonde blows into their blends here?
Wind tunnel.
Yup.
That's the punchline.
You don't ask for the punch.
We'll also,
where's the punchline there?
Now it's an anchoring me cause like I keep picturing my dad.
Those were my dad.
I'd be,
I'd be infuriated too because they hear that you're a comedian.
Data transfer.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I love these jokes.
I know.
You really do.
Why is it good to have a blonde passenger in your car?
I have no idea.
You can park in the handicap.
The mind doesn't get it.
I haven't heard these blinds.
All six foot grass.
I know.
I Google them.
Some things are all good stuff.
What are the worst six years and a blondes life?
I don't know.
Third Grade.
I'm exhausted.
I'm tired.
He's never laugh at anything.
Any comedian like
blondes not be given coffee breaks.
I give up.
It takes too long to retrain them.
I like that one.
Right.
Good job
making your five names.
I can't believe this one.
Is this kind of stuff go on forever and know it's the reaction so bad.
You get a blonde to marry you.
I don't know.
I'm tell her she's pregnant,
boy.
All right.
I think that's enough,
right?
I said No.
That's a good amount
I wanted to tell you about.
Those are good job.
I wanted to tell you about this tape.
Yeah.
He has been the best study we had done.
We had a lot of fun with you guys.
You guys went overboard and loft,
generosity,
kindness.
It was a German
of the visit is when we went to get coffee with them at the country club and
then um,
we get the people that don't know the country called means the mall.
Yeah.
Um,
and then your mom went into lengthy detail about her urethra opening surgery.
That was terrible.
Last time it was malpractice medical malpractice suits and deaths randomly.
They would just drop them on you this time.
It was,
she had 20 years,
30 years or 40 years ago.
She was like cheating a lot and then they're like,
we're just going to open your urethra more.
And the doctor scheduled it without examining.
It's like such a gross long story.
You don't mind thing that was funny was that,
see to me it's very normal that somebody does what she's doing now,
which is telling you their feelings about how much they appreciate it and you're
like so uncomfortable.
She texted us last night like I want to,
I cracked.
I can't even repeat the text back to you because I couldn't read it.
Whenever somebody expresses their feelings to me,
I get so uncomfortable.
It's just not in my family.
If you,
if you express your feelings,
it's a sign of weakness and you will be ridiculed.
So funny to me.
So nobody would say like,
thanks for taking care of us.
It was a blast.
Are you crazy?
Latin culture,
it's about over selling that you don't just go,
thanks for showing me a good time.
You have to go into the detail about,
you know,
all,
like you remember the things and like how that made you feel and I don't know.
In our house it's,
thank you.
Okay,
thanks.
Okay.
I gotta go like you don't,
you just say thank you once and then that's it.
Or You,
maybe you send a card so that you don't have to actually say it.
But for me,
the expression of her feelings,
like what she say goodbye to me last night and she was telling me all this stuff
like I couldn't,
I couldn't get away fast so far.
I can't get away fast enough.
Last night when they left,
Oh my God,
I got a big speech about their gratitude,
about what a great trip.
Then they both called from the hotel like an hour later to say it again.
Oh boy.
Then attacks.
Then I woke up to a new text message and then they called me again this morning
in addition to just saying it to like,
yeah,
it's just,
that would never happen in my family.
Never.
But the thing is,
if somebody doesn't say that it's supposed to mean that they really didn't have
a good time.
So in your family,
if they don't go over the overboard,
it means it was just like an okay trip flavor.
Oh yeah.
That's a lot.
It's a lot of pressure sending about food.
Like if yes,
if they try it and they go and you go,
how is it?
And somebody goes,
it's good.
That means this isn't good.
Because if it's really good,
you would go on and on.
You know,
like they did about the restaurant.
You remember how many times they talked about their leg.
So your dad didn't like the dinner I made last night.
He did like it.
He didn't go overboard,
but he did like it because he talked about it.
Um,
even when we were,
well,
I hate it.
That's all I care about it.
He must've been hungry.
Yeah.
It's not as favorite though.
He likes like steak.
I Made Shrimp Pasta.
That was good.
I liked it a lot.
I liked it.
It's one of our favorites.
But yeah,
the feelings.
I can't,
I don't like it.
Like I liked doing nice things for people,
but I don't like to hear the thank you.
It's,
I don't like it'd be a bit much.
It makes me very uncomfortable
dairy.
Yeah.
I absolutely can find words to thank you for these moments.
And Ellis,
is it that the only,
the only sadness that I cannot make him love me?
Yeah.
I want him to kiss me to heartbeat,
you know?
Oh,
just takes time though.
Yeah.
But it was here for six days.
What I really enjoy was all the kisses I got.
You guys went overboard.
Yeah.
All the kisses and hugs and love I got from Ellis was really,
really nice that I was version of
being like the underwater Champsi he was trying to jab,
Jabber with it.
You're saying that you and I repeat the same patterns that your parents saying
like,
Oh,
let's get me a lot of hugs and kisses.
Oh my God.
So funny.
Last time you were here we talked about how there's a whole segment of the of
the population is non-binary.
Do you remember that?
That is not what non binary.
I think we should revisit this later.
Let's take a break.
I love it though.
I love listening to them.
I laughed at them all week.
They were here.
I was finding they're so funny.
Uh,
Vincent Donoff,
Rio Batman,
shit like that.
Freeze.
Good guy.
Um,
yeah,
this is a here,
let me do this.
This is something that maybe will cleanse the palate and then we can wrap up the
show.
Okay.
Fuck my triple d slot wife.
There you go.
Of course,
if we can.
I forgot that.
Sorry.
I get the old trumpet out today.
Oh boy.
This guy can play the trumpet like you wouldn't believe.
Oh my goodness.
He's farting into his trumpet.
That's incredible.
Have we found the new king asked for it?
I don't know.
But this guy,
I mean,
he's got a cool,
can't trying to tell you something when I,
I know when you discover something big on your mom's house,
you feel it.
Yeah.
Like when we discovered king ass rapper,
that was a big fine.
There's been a few of those.
Yeah.
This feels special.
It does.
I mean,
I like that he's wearing a lab coat and a wig and he needs to get rid of it.
To me,
he doesn't need those theatrically.
Oh.
I think it dresses it up.
It becomes more of a performance because he's,
he's just ted,
you know,
when he's,
when he's wearing his regular clothes and now he's this,
but trumpet master doctor,
Dr. Trump.
Anyway.
Yeah.
That's pretty neat.
Wow.
Focus.
Yeah.
You really got to put that up on there.
Tight.
Yeah.
Even just to do your mouth,
it's very hard to blow a trumpet,
actually.
Yeah.
That's a really,
that's a real talent.
This guy.
I hope there are more hope we get to see more from doctor,
but trumpet Dr. But trumpet.
Right.
Um,
how,
what a talent that's a gene.
Um,
anything else?
We've already done our dates.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's in the past.
There you go.
Thank you guys for listening.
I love you John.
See Gene.
Uh,
we'll see you next week.
Bye guys.
This is
jazz.
I can't imagine what the enthusiasm was about.
[inaudible]
ew.
Yeah.
That's
the most disturbing dad.
Yeah.